this is some terrible news because I
just learned that climate change is
actually threatening cocoa production
which means less chocolate for people
who love it like me and that changes
everything so I've come to dandelion
chocolate in San Francisco to talk to
someone who deals with chocolate
production firsthand
hi I'm Greg Alexander I'm the chocolate
sorcerer here at dental and chocolate
what that means is I travel around the
world finding cacao that we use to make
our chocolate so first let me tell you
right when I walked into the place the
aroma the chocolaty aroma hit me like a
ton of bricks I'm having an emotional
moment right now but what's making it
more emotional right now is the bitter
forecast my chocolate sorcerer is giving
me about the future of chocolate people
don't think of climate change that's
something that they have to worry about
that grows on the tree and it are the
beans that actually have the chocolate
so these are the bad boys that are in
danger by climate change if it impacts
cacao farmers in Belize it impacts you
a world without talking is a miserable
miserable place that none of us want to
imagine all over Central America people
have been telling us their fathers and
grandfathers and great-grandfather's
never had seen weather acting this way
the rainy season which usually ends at a
very defined time now suddenly has
extended much longer cuz this is a crop
they've been working on their whole
lives and it's possible it's going to go
away
how could you stand here and just like
not drool
watch this all day I literally feel like
a kid and I in a candy factory
all of these changes that are affecting
the farmers cost money we end up
spending more money on the beans and if
we end up spending more money on the
mean that means our chocolate ends up
Korea can price - I can't imagine a
world where this would be more scarce or
more expensive it's just not fair it's
it's a bummer I mean like this is
something to deal with all the time
right and it's like it really is how do
we deal with breakups or hormonal
fluctuations or or general sadness I
don't have to think about that I'm
hoping I'll never be around for the
moment when there's no chocolate left